[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: So let's be clear.
Launch screens are all the rage
nowadays with material design.
But you have to make sure that
you do it in the right way.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and
doing launch screens properly
results in a great
branded experience.
But the wrong way could hurt the
user perception of performance.
Remember, when the
user launches your app,
they'll be shown a launch
screen while your app is loading
and getting ready to display.
If your application
launches pretty quick,
then this preview window is only
displayed for a quick flash,
and then your app will appear.
However, if you have a
slow-loading experience,
this image can hang around on
screen for quite some time,
causing users to
either exit out.
Or you could get the
dreaded Application
Not Responding dialog.
Now, some developers, in
order to hide this slow launch
experience, decide to theme
their app's launch screen so
that it's thematically
consistent with the rest
of the app rather than looking
like the system theme start
window.
Let's be clear.
While this seems like it
solves the problem, it doesn't.
See, in this scenario, the
screen may look better.
But that doesn't make
it immune to users
exiting due to slow load times
or the ANR dialog popping up.
Basically, you're just
covering up the problem.
Another way to cover this up is
to turn off the initial startup
window using the Window
Disable Preview attribute.
When you do this, rather
than the launch screen being
displayed, nothing is shown.
So the Home screen sticks
around until your app suddenly
pops up.
This feels like a different
problem to the user--
basically, what appears
to be the screen freezing
or stop responding to input.
And they sit there and just
jam their finger at it.
Listen, user perception of your
launch time is really important
and not something
you want to mess up.
So if you're going to put in
some launch screen branding,
make sure to do
it the right way.
First, you should
address your load time
issues of your application.
Now, things like
long view inflation,
lots of object instantiation, or
too many resources being loaded
are common things which can
be fixed to allow a faster
experience for your users.
Check out the videos that
we've done on those topics.
When that's done, and
only when that's done,
you can think about
your loading screens.
And if you're going to do
it, do it the right way.
Rather than disabling
the Preview window,
it's recommended to follow the
common material design patterns
and provide a simple
custom drawable
for the starting activity.
This will cause your app
to display your custom
drawable as a Startup window
rather than the default one.
However, once it's time
for the app to load,
you need to set
your activity theme
to the real theme you want
inside of your onCreate method.
The result is a nice
branding experience,
coupled with quick load times,
resulting in happier users.
And that's really what
performance is all about,
right?
Faster apps leading
to happier users?
That's why you should check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns content.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ community for other
great tips and tricks.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]